OK 好 那我们继续往下然后我们刚才讲了很多关于东哥个人的一些成长的故事以及他自己的一些观点那接下来我们去转到这个团队的部分就是关于APN这个团队因为其实可能直播间有的同学比如说有的公司可能他想成立APN团队对吧然后可能也有的正在做APN团队的同学那可能对这个部分会比较感兴趣那首先第一个点肯定是关于这个团队的成立的背景嘛因为我们要成立这样一个团队肯定是需要一些
发展的契机嘛那东哥可以大概介绍一下吗比如说像app上他是怎么样去成立的好呀好呀大概就是在17年的那个时候其实字节业务发展比较比较快速比较蓬蓬的一个阶段那么可能17年的时候我们字节雨后春损般的冒出了非常多的一些新产品所谓当时大家细称为这个app工厂对吧可能有抖音火山然后董车地飞出等等各种各样的app
然后每个App它的当时发展的也都不错在一个快速迭代的阶段然后当时一个现状就是在移动短领域我们的基础架构测其实的一些基础设施其实非常薄弱的无论是比如说我们的组建的管理CSSD然后还是APM对吧各个方向还是都非常薄弱的基础比较弱然后与此同时
大家也都知道APM这个方向其实是一个比较刚缺的事情你不可能说我把代码上线了对吧我不做任何的监控我没有任何的优化那么相当于你在线上去裸奔假如说某一天可能线上发生大规模的崩溃你也没有感觉到那肯定这不是一个非常好的一个事情那么当时一个现状可能在字节大部分一个app都在用一些免费的一些散发碰台
比如说 当时主要在用的是firebase的前身fabricfabric 它本身的一个问题是什么首先这个平台当时确实也不错它的一些crush监控能力然后大家用的也比较习惯但是它也会有一些自己的问题比如说它对稳定性问题的它的覆盖其实不完整它只能监控到一些普通意义上的一些crush对一些启动的卡死
比如说OM类问题它是完全没有能力去去监控和定位的然后其次我们在快速迭代的过程中我们会发现我们字节内部的一些研发同学各个团队还是有一些定位化的一些诉求比如说当线上的某个问题对吧有一些量级的暴涨一些激增之后我们希望能够第一时间去接到一些报警对吧第一时间去把这个问题去分给对应模块的owner去push
鋪子對應同學解決當時一個現狀就是Fabric反正據我所知是沒有什麼報警的機制頂多說他給你發一個郵件發一個郵件告訴你哪個問題爆發了但是郵件這個東西它這個提醒就非常弱有可能你沒有主動去收這個郵件的話這個問題的影響就非常大了那麼基於我們自身的研發流程做一個打通我們想更快的去做一些問題的報警做一些
问题的原因的一个自动的一个定位包括自动的一个问题的分发那么比如说我们提需求给Fabric这显然不太现实对吧可能一个更现实更可控的一个方式还是通过我们字眼那么其实最最开始的契机就这样就相当于我们字节在17年那个时候业务的快速发展然后同时APM这个方向也是一个钢区同时在一些第三方的解决方案无法完全满足我们当时的一个诉求
所以就开始了这个自言的一个道路对 大概是这样一个期间OK 对 刚才东哥分享就是关于在字节这一块为什么会成立这个APM团队背景那其实这就有一个问题了因为刚才调查到就是其实是一个业务的快速的发展然后各方面诉求都在所以会有APM这个团队那这里就问因为不一定所有团队都会有这样的业务那在东哥你的理念下面觉得什么样的团队需要有APM
OK我個人觀點是這樣我個人觀點就是無論你是任何技術戰任何形態的產品只要你是跟技術相關的我認為你這個團隊都需要有一篇那無論是你是字眼還是說用一些開源方案還是說採購對吧更不一樣的形式你必須得有那什麼原因呢假如說比如說你做一個客戶端對吧假如說你一啟動
即使你是一个串业公司可能你这个东西新上线你们公司人很少用户也不多假如说用户再用你的产品的过程中启动就发生了一个闪退你觉得用户还会再愿意用你们产品吗它是一个非常非常严重的一个体验的问题那假如说你写的后端服务你请求量稍微高一点就开始当街就开始挂那么你觉得你这个在用户体验看来你这个功能是正常的吗假如说你写了一个前端的页面
假如说经常性的发现一些这个白屏加载太慢的时候你觉得你这个产品还有可用性可言嘛对吧所以我觉得所以总结下了我觉得认为无论你是任何形态一个纪录站只要无论任何形式的一个产品形态都需要有一片子只不过可能在我们不同的一个发展阶段你需要有一些不同的侧种比如说我是一个创业公司对吧可能一开始我需要用一些
非常简单非常成本非常低的一个方式去做这个事情那么最起码的我们得做一些线上的一些稳定性的监控对吧比如说你可以用免费的一些方案然后也或者说一些开源的方案但我觉得这个东西一定是得有的因为如果没有的话它会严重威胁到你们的业务发展否则的话就是你在业务在线上就是一个裸奔的状态对
啊我理解了所以其实东哥你讲这个APM就是呃其实其实比如像我们正常的一些crash啊这些监控的东西它其实也是属于APM的一部分对吧只是说对啊对啊当然当然而且是而且是APM当中比较重要的一部分因为这类问题往往它的影响是是最大的对可能这种收入影响是最最最最严重的对就包括其实我觉得东哥你们后面做的那些包括内存的一些线上化的监控啊然后包括一些
甚至可能对于一些现成啊这样的一些更深层的问题监控它其实是属于APP的部分但是只是说它可能会钻得更深也是根据你当时的业务的发展以及一些现实中的问题然后提出了一些解决方案我是不可以这么对对对你这个理解是没有任何问题的完全完全是准确的就是我刚才也提到你在不同的一个发展阶段你可能你个重心是不同的那假如说你是一个创业公司你的研发的人数非常少我们没有太多的人力去投入到一些
可能非常细节或者一些非常有深度的一些方向去钻研那么可能我们就只能顾一些最主要的一些场景对吧可能最严重的一些问题我们只要有能力去发现去解决就OK了那么假如说你的业务越来越做越大对吧那么你研发团队人数越来越多那么在发展的同时我们可能需要关注到更多的一些事情就是我在PPT中最开始分享的一个APM的业务全景图那么最理想的情况下
假如说你们业务团队发展得非常好非常壮大那么可能我们在各个方向都需要有一些投入还是跟你的产品发展阶段有关系OK 时间关键我们就不展开了因为已经9点半了可能我们今天会超一点时间那这就刚才我们讲的其实是一个APP的扫码了我理解大家理解之后呢其实比如说有的公司确实想成立一个自己的APP团队叫自己做APP那做这个事情需要做一些哪些准备呢
OKOK这个问题我觉得可以从几个方面回答吧我觉得首先既然是一个APM团队那么我觉得第一要素肯定得是人对吧你也不能招到人然后我们需要哪些人呢我个人玩哈就如果你想把APM这个事情做得比较好比较完善的话你需要做一些不同职能的人材储备什么意思呢比如说假如说今天某个公司想成立APM团队那么你会发现
你仅仅有客户端研发是不够的比如说你只有安卓或者只有ISO同学做SDK你是完全不够的因为我们需要有一些后台去收集汇总去聚合这些数据去分析这些数据我们也需要一些前端的一些页面去帮助我们研发同学去消费这些数据也有可能我们需要一些产品来出一些产品规划我们怎么样去设计一些功能对吧所以一些产品化的一些表达所以说
我觉得在人才储备这个点上我们需要建立一个可闭环的最好建立一个可闭环的多智能的一个研发团队包括我们客户端 服务端 前端甚至是这个产品和测试什么是可闭环呢我这边稍微解释一下因为我看到有些公司他想做一篇但是牵头的同学往往是客户端的同学OK 那么这个时候你去说服一个后端的负责人说能不能出两个同学来帮我
去做这个事情那有可能在一个后端的leader的视角下他会觉得这个事情他不是非常的认可这件事情的价值或者说他会觉得投入产量比非常低对吧有可能他投入的人力就完全没法保证可能只是说顶多说借你两个同学然后做一两个月那么假如说这一两个月之后就像一个临时工一样那么这样我们做出来一个系统或者是平台
它的一个可用性是完全没法保障的所以说最好我们还是由整个公司的一些比较有话语权的一些技术力的去牵头去组建一个多指能的与他团队包括后端前端这样我认为你在发展的时候整个团队的发展状态会包括你的业务推进会比较顺利这是第一个点人才储备然后第二个点就是说有了人才之后我们需要做一个合理规划因为
APM这个领域它的确实涉及到方方面面的事情很多那么我们需要这个teamleader需要有一些团队的专家有对这个领域有一些比较深刻的一些理解和认知对吧我们需要明切我们需要做一些科学的合理的规划我们需要明确在当前这个阶段我们最急需解决的问题是什么对吧我们最急需解决的用户或者说我们开发者的痛点到底是什么
需要有一个这个有一个测重对吧有一些重心的一些调整从我个人的一个观点来看理论上我们其实应该先先做一些线上的监控然后再去覆盖到线下然后同时我们的稳定性监控会去比性能的监控会会更重要一些对大概是这样一个预先级就是需要我们团队的负责人去结合自己的业务特点去理出去规划出一些这个事情的预先级
也有可能比如说一些特殊型态的App比如说电商他可能更更注重一些这个流伤性比如说短视频更更终于流伤性或者功耗对吧假如说你这个视频越刷越卡这个手机越烫的话用户可能也很难去去去留存对可能对于这样一些类型的产品这个功耗以及流伤性来说也是比较重要就需要大家需要我们团队负责人对自己的一个产品形态有一个比较好的一个认识
然后再整理出去又先解然后第三点我认为在你如果你想搭建一个APM团队想落定一些工作成果的时候一个比较现实的一个问题就是假如说你是一个中台团队对吧那可能我们现在的Apple已经接入了一些监控的平台对吧我们可能接入这个firebase对吧那么一个非常现实的问题你怎么去说服
一些app去切到你自言的一些监控系统对吧这个问题非常现实对吧假如说我是一个app负责人你告诉我你必须得用我自言的一个系统那我肯定会有一个疑问你这个能力到底是强在哪里对吧你有什么理由去说服我做这样一个切换对吧你比别人强在哪里假如说你没有一个数据上的一个支撑的话这个事情就比较尴尬比如说
我们同样崩溃了这个100次那比如说firebase抓到100次那你的sdk或者你的平台上只能看到90次那么我认为你这个效果其实还不如一些我们现在的一些解决方案对吧那么做我做一个app的一个研发负责人的话我是没有动力去做这样一个切换的所以说说这些的意思就是说我们我们大家如果是特别是一个中台的团队的话你在推进一些业务去接入的时候一定要去
想办法去做一些自我的监控和迭代就说你得去了解你当前的覆盖的能力是不是比竞评更好的最好是你有一些指标上的一些支撑对吧我这里举个例子比如说我们团队一开始在推这个SDK切换的时候也是遇到了一些不小的阻力但是后面我们意识到这个问题我们就想办法把我们自己的监控能力通过一些数据分析
通过一些脚本我们跟一些三方的平台去做对比比如说这个版本我们总共假如说线上总共在挥度发生了这个500次crash比如说这个fabric抓了500次那么我们抓到了495次ok那么可能我们漏掉了5次对吧那么这5次的原因是什么比如说可能我们在sdk在抓取的过程中发生了一些20次的崩溃或者卡死那么我们需要用一些自监控的一些手段我们需要在现场去
去埋一些日誌去分析我們看一下我們在哪一個環節中斷了發生了異常然後再根據一些現場信息去做一些自我的完善和優化然後再做一些像一輪一輪的迭代那我相信最終你可以做到你的這個能力與這個競評或是你想我們現在再用的一些這個平臺
能跟他的能力做到完全的对标甚至是你的效果比他更好这样的话你有一些数据的支撑他是非常有说服力的对吧那么你也可以说我们的Crash监控已经上包了一个完整这个完整完整度已经超过了这个fabric然后我们与此同时我们还有这个卡斯监控以及OM监控的能力那我作为对方来说是不是这个切换或者说接入的意愿会强很多呢嗯对这就是说
我们在一个落地场景的切入的时候一定要有意识的去做一些字监控和自我的一些迭代和优化OK我简单总结一下东哥说的三个非常普通的点第一个就是你要做这件事你需要有人对吧所以这个人是怎么去建立起这个团队然后第二件事就是你要做社友有限级嘛要把最重要的事情先做掉那第三个还就是说你要有进品的话你比进品强返什么地方
我理解就這三個點OK好的然後我們再進入這個環境就是因為其實做了這麼久的APM嘛我不禁你應該是做了很多年了那在這個過程中有沒有困惑過你怎麼處理的因為我覺得可能對於直播間同學來說大家在工作過程中其實也會面臨一些自己在記錄上的一些困惑所以我想聽東哥你是怎麼去處理這樣的一些對於比如說你自己堅持的一個方向然後很久然後突然發生一個困惑你怎麼去處理呢嗯OK
事实上我觉得困惑可能简单提两个点第一个点就是说跟刚才我分享的一些新的有一点关系我们在我们中台做这个APM SDK包括我们整个监控平台的一个初期其实我们业务落地的一个进度其实不太顺利的问题刚才也提到可能我们在推进的时候会遇到一些阻力可能各个业务的负责同学有时候并不是非常的配合他可能会质疑你的一些
至于你的一些东西吧有可能而且你的新纪录的SDK可能你自身的一些稳定性包括对一些性能的一些损耗可能都会有一些提出一些质疑这本身是一些非常正常的但是在当时那个阶段确实是比较矛人可能这个过程我们持续了几个月到半年的时间当然最终问题都解决了但是在这个过程中是比较
而且在这个过程中会伴随着非常多的一些复返会或者是安靠对吧可能别人在接入你这个过程中我发现有可能我用你这个功能我感觉它没有以前的体验更好或者说你在这个因为你新接入SDK可能稳定性性能并没有做得非常的一个完美可能在接入过程中会发现你自身的一些
问题这就很尴尬比如说你做一个监控夸杀还是自己夸杀是不是有点有点说不过去对吧遇到过几例类似这样的问题然后每初这样一次的问题就会让那个中台跟业务业务的同学这样一个信任关系会有一些会造成一些裂痕吧对吧可能别人不信任你会有问题那可能你之后的推进会比较麻烦
OK那么遇到这个问题我们的解决对策就是首先OK我们可能一开始不要把摊子铺得太大可能我们就专注一个最重要的一个点对吧我们专注一个MVP版本比如说我们这一个版本我们就只做CRUSH监控什么其他的性能网络我们都不做OK我们就只把这一个功能点做好做得完美对吧然后持续的打磨这样的话我们引入的风险也自然会更少然后这个过程就更容易去落地
然后其次就是你在跟一些业务对接的时候一定要去做一些提前的沟通就我们一定要跟对方去明确我们再满足了什么样的条件下我们可以去接入这个SDK对吧去完成这样一个平台的切换一定要对齐一个目标然后同时好有一些数据上的一些体现和支撑这样是最客观最有说服力的对吧这些怎么做刚才已经说了这边也不重复了
就你需要快速的去收敛这个问题OK然后这是最初阶段的一个最大的一个困惑那可能在做了几年之后有伴随而来有另外一个困惑就是可能会有一些同学会有一些这样一个声音那可能APM我们已经做了很多事情了那可能比如说我们在业界上普遍能看到的一些方案对吧或者说我们最常遇到的一些问题我们其实已经解决了
那么我们后面做什么呢是不是会越来越无视可做了对这个东西非常成熟了那么有没有可能说已经进了一个维护阶段对吧可能我在这个团队当中呢我的成长是不是很慢了对吧我的业务产出会不会越来越少了OK那么针对这个问题其实我给说的答案其实就是我们还是需要去挖掘一些业务上的一些问题和痛免
对吧比如说我在一开始PTT体重起到的我们对于一些遗难问题的一些定位和解决对吧我觉得现在远远还没有到假如说我们线上发生了一路CRUSH我们能够百分之百能把这个原因给排查出来然后并且把这个问题给很快的FIX掉我觉得远远还没达到这样一个理想的状态对然后我们可以在很多的一个技术生动上去做挖掘比如说CRUSH比如说这个
內存比如說這個卡絲卡頓對吧其實每個技術方向我們都可以去往深度上去去挖然後與此同時我們可以去除了這個監控本身我們可以去做一些這個橫向的一些拓展比如說我們可以做測試左翼對吧我們能不能在在線下通過一些更更多的一些手段去提前的去幫助用戶去挖掘或者是發現
暴露一些问题对吧提前做一些修复然后同时与此同时我们能不能做一些当发现问题之后我们能不能针对一些比如说T系统的底层bug比如说一些基础库的一些移南的问题我们能不能做一些统一的修复方案对相当于我们能不能在整个APM在研发的流程中我们能够涉足更多的一些环节和领域这样才能发挥出更大的一个体验出更多的一个价值我就简单分享这两个点
我觉得第二个问题可能登革是有点有点烦了有点烦耳塞了因为我觉得可能很多人不会碰到你这样的问题就你们发现把问题做到终点了我觉得可能第一个问题会帮助一点对吧第二个问题确实是因为我其实也认识很多在做APM的一些团队他们其实可能还存在很多都在一个阶段就是说我们的APM其实还不够健全还有好的东西没有做好甚至可能一想到说
对比较一些一线大厂发现还有很多很大的差距对所以我觉得这个就是高处不胜喊嘛我是这么理解当然我觉得对第一个点对大家还是非常惊艳的也就是有帮助的这个惊艳就帮你碰到一些阻力的时候怎么去解决这个问题ok 那我们就到最后问题吧今天确实有点超时了呃就是我讲一下比如说你的
怎么讲呢?就是因为你也在成长,你的团队肯定也是在成长,包括现在虽然说已经到了一个比较后期的阶段,那你觉得你的成长和团队的成长是什么关系呢?我觉得总结来说,个人的成长,我觉得无论是作为团队管理者,还是团队中的议员,你个人的成长和团队的成长一定是相互相成,互相成就的,什么意思呢?比如说
你自身的一個能力和技術水平再提升那麼你在完成一些需求或者說無論是一些技術難題還是一些複雜方案的設計的時候你一定會做得更加的出色可能你的效率會更高可能你的擴展性會更好你的最終體現出的一個收益或者成果會更明顯那麼與此同時你的業務在發展OK可能我們越往後面做我們會涉足更多的一些深水區一些技術挑戰更多的一些領域和方向
那麼與此同時你帶來的一些技術挑戰會更大那麼可能你會面臨一些更多的一些棘手的問題更複雜的一些問題對吧它會對你的能力有一些更高的一些要求那麼在完成這些需求在在攻克這些技術難題的同時你個人能力一定也是在互相成長的我覺得這樣這就是一個正向的循環對所以說個人能力和團隊的成長我覺得一定是相互相成互相成就的對然後我可以這邊也可以去分享我們團隊的幾個做事情的理念我認為對
無論是對個人發展還是對整個團隊發展比較有幫助的第一個點就是說我們需要做正確而不是容易的事情可能這個點它只是一個觀點大家可能也都能聽過但是據我發現在工作中真正把這個點做得很完美做得很出色或者身體例行的同學畢竟還是少可能很多時候大家覺得
有一些很简单的一些方式可以做到这个事情但是可能它比较粗糙那我可以那可能大部分同学还是选择一些很低成本的吧很方便一些一些途径去去做这些事情但是我希望大家在在日常工作中可能能能能更更更深入的去思考这些话然后并且把它做到一个之前合议对很多时候如果一个如果一个事情一个方案就是方案你想做的比较
比较完美你想把问题解决比较彻底的话那一定是它的难度会比较大的吧它的成本是比较高的那我觉得这个问题是不可避免的然后其次就是无论是我们个人或者团队在遇到问题的时候我鼓励大家不要去去照顾这个问题那可能比如说你在修复一个bug对吧可能ok你可能原来用了a写法ok有crush或者有一些性能的问题那么你换了一种编码的一些方式时间方式你发现这个问题不存在了ok
你看死你把問題解決了但是有可能這個問題可能它某一天又以另外一種形式給出現了對吧可能你並沒有徹底的去解決它所以說我覺得大家在修bug或者說遇到一些技術難題的時候還是盡量的去去鑽研一下它的底層原理想辦法能在一些根上就分一出它的一些柔軟的靠子想辦法在根上去解決這個問題這樣我們相當於也會給後人去賞賣一些坑對吧對你個人的一個成長也是有非常大的一個幫助
再一個就是因為作為中台呢我一直給大家灌輸的一個理念就是我希望大家把一個你工作的成果發這個把我們中台的一個槓桿就作用發揮到極致的什麼意思呢什麼是槓桿呢中台呢天然的我們我們Sdk我們平台會對接可能自己NLG業務對吧可能你你的一個工作成果比如說你做了一個啟動優化你做了一個內存優化那我們天然的就會可以肯定成本的去接入到自己的各個業務那麼這個
这个成果和收益其实是可以规模化的对吧相对我们可以很很简单很低层面的去做一些这个惩罚做一些收益的惩罚然后其次我也我也我个人包括我我非常会鼓励团队会做一些技术的成绩和分享对然后我也我也鼓励大家把把一次整理的素材然后应用到各个区大比如说你可以发进文章你可以做技术分享你可以做一个视频的特长
你可以做一些外部功耗的投稿你甚至可以上一些技術大会做一些专利这就是所谓的高杠杆比如说一次的技術审电我的素材只整理了一次但是我的收益确实各个渠道都可以拿到这就是一个高杠杆的事情所以说总结下来我觉得这几个原则可能对大家成长会不会有一些帮助OK 移动
敦戈分享这三个原则确实是我觉得其他两个就我个人如果是说我自己啊其他两个我觉得我是应该是能还是能做的但是我觉得第一个确实很难我从我个人角度来说这个真的非常非常难这可能也是因为不同职能关系吧因为我带的可能主要是业务团队但是敦戈带的是重态团队嘛确实可能在一些理念上面需要有一些有一些不一样的业务团队
我说心里话因为在右团内所以可能我们的时候会选择一些简单但是相对来说能接受的方案我们可能就OK了对但是可能对于中台来说确实这种坚持是非常有必要的能给大家一些真的非常完美的一些解决方案这个不容易好的